eh de confirmarse la mayoría republicana
en la cámara de representantes qué tanto
afectaría esto la gobernabilidad del
presidente Joe
Muchísimas gracias por la invitación
ciertamente va a tener una complejidad
muy particular todas las leyes entran
por la cámara baja y el orden de la
importancia que le quiera dar el
presidente de la cámara baja lo va a
determinar los republicanos o sea van a
tener que negociar muchísimo más que en
la primera parte de este periodo que
ciertamente los gobernaba lo lo manejaba
la cámara baja el partido demócrata pero
estaban trancados siempre en el proceso
del senado Yo creo que el senado Así va
a terminar siendo igual falta la
decisión el arito no hay Nevada pero ya
va a haber segunda vuelta en en Georgia
hay que entender una realidad Este es un
país Federal cada cada estado tiene su
propia normativa su propia legislación y
se decide en cada estado como se eligen
los senadores Georgia determinó desde
hace varios años que que ahora se
necesita una segunda vuelta para
conseguir la mayoría absoluta para ver
quién va a tener el senador de Georgia
En mi opinión va a terminar siendo 50 50
Ese es mi apreciación hoy en el senado
con la determinación de la
vicepresidenta Pero qué pasa a segundo
plano porque todo va a pasar por la
cámara de diputado a la misma velocidad
que quieran los republicanos y todo
indica que los republicanos por muy poco
estrechos van a ganar la la cámara baja
no era lo que se esperaba no era lo que
ellos aspiraban Eso es lo malo de tener
altas expectativas que a la larga el
ganador va a terminar siendo los
demócrates de los republicanos a pesar
de que se ganó ahora Cuál es la
importancia de la cámara de
representantes en Estados Unidos porque
normalmente se cree que el senado es el
que tiene un mayor peso
Sí eso es lo que en principio uno cree
desde América Latina tiene esa
expectativa pero la cámara baja es la
que determina el orden de la entrada de
todas las legislaciones de todas las
normas y todos los cambios todas las
todos los procesos presupuestarios
legislativos entran por la cámara baja y
quien determina el orden de esta cámara
el orden de importancia de esta
normativa y esto de estos temas
presupuestarios Fiscales o inclusive
inclusive de investigación pasan por la
cámara baja primero antes de llegar al
senado O sea la cámara baja es la puerta
de entrada del poder legislativo y
después de hacer aprobado en cámara baja
va al senado ahora Cuáles serían las
principales políticas de biden que se
verían afectadas ante una mayoría
republicana en la cámara
Bueno yo creo que todo lo que le queda
el presidente va a ir va a ser una gran
va a tener que tener generar una gran
capacidad de negociar con el nuevo líder
de la cámara baja que va a ser
republicano y seguramente Ahí va a haber
un un buen proceso de negociación
veremos Próximamente reuniones en la
casa blanca con líderes de los
republicanos del Congreso y del senado
en republicano tanto demócratas como
republicanos en la casa blanca para
negociar y acordar estos términos de
cómo va a ser este proceso legislativo
en estos dos próximos años que le quedan
al presidente byden